you know your personality creates your
personal reality that's it and your
personality is made with how you think
how you act and how you feel so if you
keep thinking the same way you keep
acting the same way you keep feeling the
same way everything stays the same in
your life because nothing changes in
your life until you change right so
turns out if you keep thinking the same
way making the same choices doing the
same things creating the same
experiences and feeling the same
emotions or responding to your life in
the exact same way you keep doing that
your biology tends to get more rigid we
fire and wire the same service we
hardwire our brain and they it only
takes a small stimulation or small
fodder a response to someone or
something and like a sequence of
thoughts it just turns on automatically
hey it's Evan Carmichael and I make
these videos because when I started my
first business I really struggled to
believe myself I was making 300 bucks a
month and quit on my business partner
and the thing that saved me was watching
the stories of successful entrepreneurs
they gave me strategies as well as hope
and belief that just maybe I could do it
myself as well and I hope that this
video here today helps you get a little
bit more belief in yourself because I
still need the videos for myself today
too so today let's learn how to create
some magic in our lives with Joe
dispenza enjoy
so your biology your neurochemistry your
hormones your genes everything stays the
same because you're the same so crisis
and Trauma is always the thing that gets
a person to really start looking at how
do I really change right so so we want
to tell people let's not wait for that
let's let's learn and change in a state
of growth and inspiration so
so if you keep doing those same things
over and over again the middle life
period we we become very very
programmable
so in order for us to change we have to
become conscious of how we think we have
to become really aware of how we behave
what our habits are even how we speak
now this is a tough one we have to
really look at the emotions that we live
by every single day and and say wow this
this actually could be unworthiness this
could actually be guilt but if you're
too busy with your cell phone and your
social media and you're too busy with
your kids and running around and as well
your environment can distract you from
these feelings so
my interest is to get people to retreat
from their lives right just for
five seven days and and remove the
constant stimulation in their external
environment that reminds them of who
they think they are as a personality
to separate themselves from the people
they know and the places they go and the
things they do at the exact same time
and then fill their brain with knowledge
and information and then remind them
that they're actually creating their
life
so if your personality creates your
personal reality and that means that if
in order for you to change your personal
reality you got to change your
personality rule number two is stop
living in survival that leads perfectly
into one of the most powerful things in
your book for me anyway personally was
that this distinction between the living
in survival versus living in creation
and as you've just alluded to a lot of
people are living in survival especially
now but don't even actually know that
there's a difference between the two or
there's another place that they can
shift into can you talk to me about the
difference between survival and creation
and then I guess take us into how we can
spend more time in that places sure
creation sure well living in survival is
living in stress and as we said a moment
ago stress is when your body's knocked
out of homeostasis when it's not that of
balance we have different types of
stressors we have physical stress like
trauma or injuries or accidents we have
chemical stress like pesticides and
pollutants and flus and bacteria and
viruses and heavy metals and you have
emotional stress like traffic jams and
internet connections and second
mortgages single parenting 401ks family
tragedies and every one of these things
physical chemical or emotional knocks
your body at balance now human beings
were so unique because we can turn on
the stress response just by thought
alone instead of being chased by a lion
which was highly adaptive thousands of
years ago we turn on this primitive
nervous system to mobilize all of this
energy for some threat in the
environment
that that function allows us to begin to
survive in those conditions but when you
turn on the stress response just by
thought alone you start thinking about
some worst case scenario
you start imagining what will happen in
some future time what most people don't
know is their body begins to
physiologically change as if that event
is happening as they think about a past
bitter memory that's tattooed in the
recesses of the gray matter and they
attend to that thought that memory to
the exclusion of everything else the
body literally begins to produce the
same chemistry as if that past
experience has happened now the body is
the unconscious mind it doesn't know the
difference between an actual experience
in your life that creates an emotion an
emotion you fabricate by thought alone
to the body it's the same so people tend
to knock themselves out of balance just
by thought alone now here's the key
those survival hormones those adrenal
hormones give the body and brain A Rush
of energy and we begin to become
addicted to that Rush of energy
unconsciously and we begin to associate
the problems in our life
to reaffirm our emotional addiction so
we can remember who we think we are as a
somebody so when it gets time to end the
relationship or leave the job that
doesn't work or change some
circumstances in our life it becomes
very difficult because we can't predict
the feeling of what's going to happen
next and we hold on to the addiction so
that we can remember who we are now this
is why change becomes difficult and when
we live in those survival states without
a doubt we become over focused on the
self we become selfish because the
emotions of anger and aggression and
hatred and judgment and fear and anxiety
pain suffering hopelessness
powerlessness those
those emotions that we call normal
emotions or derivatives of those
hormones of stress and when we live by
those States we typically become very
self-indulgent very self-centered rule
number three is experiment what are some
of in the formula for example the things
that you teach to help take this
incredible knowledge and put it into
practice Yeah I mean listen I I think
the most important part is to experiment
to be curious to really see uh you know
most people they respond to their outer
environment in their outer environment
is really controlling the way they think
and feel and I say David why are you
upset today it's because of that person
of circumstance but you're really saying
is that some person or circumstance is
actually controlling the way I feel in
the way I think well most of the time
our response to the environment because
of the stress hormones actually weakens
the organism that goes a step further
that when you think about your problems
you produce the same stress response as
if it was happening your body's so
objective it's believe it's it's living
in that environmental State and it's
that constant
attack and that response from the
environment that begins to down regulate
genes and weaken the immune system so
the fundamental question is if you can
turn on the stress response by thought
alone
and the long-term effects of those
chemicals push the genetic buttons that
create disease then that means our
thoughts can make us sick so then if our
thoughts could make us sick is it
possible that our thoughts can make us
well so when a person is less responsive
less than a victim to their environment
to their environment is no longer
controlling the way they think and feel
then the next fundamental question is if
I change the way I think and feel should
it change my environment now that's
going from a victim in your life to
being a creator of your life and that's
the experiment and everybody should
believe that they are the creator of
their life and so
we teach people some basic tools the
formula really is about 10 years of
research that we were able to say you
could actually change your brain waves
and create more order in your brain the
the this sentence and incoherence that's
created when we're under stress really
causes the brain to compartmentalize and
fire out of order
and so we've demystified the process
after looking of at the tons of scans to
be able to say you could actually make
your brain work better and you can do
that in a very short amount of time also
to make sure you're actually taking
action after watching this video I've
designed a special free worksheet just
for this video the worksheet will
highlight all the Lessons Learned in
this video as well as pull out our three
favorite learnings and quotes that will
inspire you to actually do something the
worksheet will also give you space to
write down what your key takeaways are
and your specific plan of action to make
sure you're getting results if you want
the worksheet design specifically for
this video absolutely for free there's a
link in the description below go click
on it and start building the momentum in
your life and your business I'll see you
there rule number four is heal by
thought alone I know your next book for
hey ALS you are the placebo that you did
a lot of research about Placebo and I'd
love for you to share some of that with
the audience and and let them know
because I know you put a huge amount of
effort in discovering this you just
didn't take other people's word for it
you looked at of course the other
scientific literature but you did a lot
of research yourself for this yeah I'm
fascinated with the placebo response
because the placebo studies show that
anywhere from 10 to 100 percent people
can heal themselves by thought alone
and when we are told that a sugar pill
or a saline injection or a sham surgery
can produce some biological change in US
that for a certain percentage of people
they actually begin to select the
potential in the quantum field called I
am healthy
and may begin to emotionally Embrace
what it would feel like to be healthy
and when they combine a clear intention
with an elevated emotion they begin to
change their state of being and for a
certain percentage of those people their
body begins to create their own Pharmacy
of chemicals
to match the exact chemicals of the fake
sugar pill that they're taking
so people would say that it's their
belief in this saline injection or the
drug or the surgery that gets the person
better
so I began to think well do you need a
sugar pill the Anita saline injection do
you need a sham surgery to cause people
to move into these state of being these
states of being in other words can you
teach people how to do it
and so some of the workshops that we've
been doing around the world in the last
year and a half or so
is it's become very clear that we've
seen people heal themselves of Ms of
Lupus of chronic pain of Hashimoto's
syndrome of cancer of diabetes I mean
this is uh real scientific evidence that
they're really making some substantial
changes by thought alone
and so that started happening right in
real time during our events in other
words someone with Ms that was paralyzed
in their leg who moved around in a
automatic motorized wheelchair is now
standing up in front of the room and
running around the room
you got to start thinking how did that
happen so in real time
they started signaling new genes in new
ways turning on the genes for growth and
repair and turning off the genes for the
disease and we started seeing it over
and over again so I started thinking
it's happening in real time it's like
they're taking the placebo but instead
of them putting their belief and
acceptance into something that's known
they're putting their acceptance into
the unknown and they're continuously
revisiting it until they made it known
and their body began to respond to their
mind so we brought in a team of
neuroscientists we brought in a team of
researchers physicists
and we began to measure people's brains
before and after our Advanced workshops
in other words we scanned over 500
people's brains the they came in
beginning of the event they went in
through a process where we put a
quantitative scan on their brain
they went through four days of training
and we scanned their brain after then we
randomly selected oh probably
50 or 60 people and we brought them
right up in the room hooked them up to
the brain scam and right during our
meditations we wanted to see what was
going on in their brain in real time
we have people wearing heart rate
monitors because we believe that when
you open your heart there's a change in
your heart rate rhythms it's called
heart rate variability and if you feel
appreciation and you feel loving
kindness and you feel Joy
there's an alteration in the when the
heart gets highly coherent
we noticed that when you get people's
heart coherent their brain gets coherent
when their brain gets coherent their
hard kids coherent and when your brain
is coherent you're more coherent and
when your brain works right you work
right
so we also measured the energy in the
room because people were saying oh my
God at the end of the event the energy
in the room is so incredible well I just
didn't want it to be a subjective
measurement I wanted to be an objective
measurement so we brought in the the
deputy director of the Department of
physics the University of Russia St
Petersburg with his sophisticated
instruments to measure the energy in the
ambient space of the room we measure the
energy field around people's bodies we
measured the energy centers of their
bodies we measured epigenetic changes in
urine we had people pee in cups before
and after it would spit into cups we
wanted to measure
if genes were being signaled in new ways
and the answer to all of this is that
when you give people
proper information and we use science
really as the Contemporary model of
mysticism science is what demystifies
the mystical
and they can begin to understand that
information if they learn information
they make new Connections in their brain
so there's a physical change in their
brain if they can repeat that
information now they're wiring it in
their brain
now if you give them the proper
instruction
and you get their behavior to match
their intentions they should have a new
experience and it should transform them
in some way well if we can measure that
transformation
and interpret that information that's
more information to teach transformation
and if we measure it again we can begin
to close the gap between knowledge and
experience and we learn so many amazing
things in the last year and a half and
common people when given the proper
information will do the uncommon and
they don't have to be a Buddhist monk
they don't have to be a academic they
don't have to have 50 years of training
and meditation you can develop a skill
and we saw people heal themselves by
thought alone so when I started seeing
this pattern
people were doing it by thought alone we
decided to write this book called you
are the placebo making your mind matter
and we now know
that you can invest the same belief
acceptance and surrender to that outcome
without analysis and when you understand
the scientific principles of how the
placebo works you can omit that thing
that exists outside of you that you
believe is going to change you and begin
to cultivate that state of being from
inside of you and when people are able
to do that properly they produce the
same biological changes if they took the
placebo and they're healing themselves
by thought alone rule number five is
make internal changes I wanted to take a
few minutes with you and talk about how
I came about doing all this work
about 12 years ago I was in this movie
called what the bleep do we know and in
that movie we made the effort to combine
many different principles and
theoretical science to begin to teach
people that their thoughts have
something to do with their life and to
show them that if they applied the
principles they could begin to produce
changes in their world one of the most
common questions we got as a result of
the movie is how do we do it how do we
begin to make measurable changes in our
lives and if our personality creates our
personal reality and we have to change
our personality in order to change our
personal reality why is it so hard to
change and I thought those questions
were really great questions because
people were more interested in
understanding to take those principles
and really begin to apply them
so I started teaching these conferences
and workshops around the world
and at the same time I was writing my
second book called breaking the habit of
being yourself
and what made my second book different
than my first book was in the second
book I gave people some of the tools to
use to begin to practice the inner work
and make internal changes in the way
they thought and the way they felt and
to see if it produced changes in their
outer world or in their body or in their
lives
and what I did was I took some of the
ideas and principles and studying
spontaneous remissions from diseases
that I had researched years before when
I wrote my first book and I thought
well gosh if it worked on sick people
maybe it could work on well people
and so the principles of personal change
and transformation that I learned from
hundreds and hundreds and hundreds of
people that were treating both
conventionally and unconventionally and
they were staying the same or getting
worse and all of a sudden got better I
thought well if it worked for them it
should be able to work for other people
and we should be able to replicate the
process
so
in Breaking the Habit I wanted to use
some of those principles in the how to
the how to make measurable changes in
people's thoughts and in their biology
in their genes in their chemistry and
really even in their energy and really
see if it was able to move the needle in
their lives in some way and in the first
couple years after that movie we didn't
see much change in people's lives but
people always wanted more information
and we keep we kept teaching those
workshops and conferences and then all
of a sudden
the magic started happening in fact
people started to heal by thought alone
and because we were seeing so many
significant changes I assembled a team
of researchers and scientists to begin
to measure those changes
we've done about 18 or 19 Advanced
workshops All Around the World in
measuring people's changes in a four-day
event the same thing that you'll be
learning on this online course we taught
in these past workshops
and people come for a host of different
reasons some people come because they're
suffering from a disease or they have a
chemical or physical imbalance in their
body some people come because they want
to create a new life a new job a new
relationship some people come because
they're interested in having mystical
experiences but whatever the reason is
that inspires you to become a creator of
your life the principles the very basic
principles of how to do it is exactly
the same
and I have to tell you that I never
thought that I would be standing here
telling you that common people around
the world are doing The Uncommon and
they are becoming Supernatural
and because they're becoming
Supernatural
I wrote another book called you are the
placebo where I show people how to heal
by thought alone and then it led to this
whole breakthrough of measurements and
changes in our objective scientific
findings that transcended really common
understanding of what could happen to a
person in fact we've made scientific
history in the last four years over and
over again and it's people just like you
that are doing it item number six the
last one before some very special bonus
Clips is be greater than the environment
I'm interested in the creative part and
in creatives and in artists and
musicians who access the unknown that's
what I meant by making only because
there are developing some new
neurochemistry that doesn't come from
anywhere let's talk about that the
Neurology of creativity sure well the
frontal lobe is the crowning achievement
of the human being right it's 40 percent
of your entire brain it's the symphony
leader it's the CEO it's the creative
center it's the boss when you're living
primarily unconsciously the rest of the
brain is active and the frontal loan is
dialed way down
the moment you ask a question
or you get a creative idea the moment
you speculate possibility the moment you
ask what if
the frontal lobe the seat of our
attention Our intention our creative
Center where we speculate where we
restrain emotional Reactions where we
control behaviors we have focused
concentrations where we demonstrate free
will the moment that Center turns on
like a great Symphony leader that has
connections to all other parts of the
brain and when you ask that question the
frontal lobe resources different
neurological networks that's stored in
your brain from things you've learned
and experienced and seamlessly pieces
them together to create a new level of
mind and when that happens perfectly in
Tandem and those neurons string together
you get an image or a picture in your
head that internal representation is
called intention now you're locking on
to something
the true passionate Creator the true
artist then begins to see that vision
and begins to emotionally embrace the
outcome the moment they begin to
emotionally embrace the outcome their
brain and body are living in the future
in the present moment and when they're
transfixing their idea in it they begin
to lay down new neurological networks to
reflect that Vision now
we all do this all the time right
everything that's coming out of our
mouth is a new creative moment as long
as you're in the creative process right
and you're present right so then once
you get that Vision now you have to go
through a process of bringing it to life
now
this is where the rubber meets the road
it certainly is because we get these
moments all the time and do we do
anything with it exactly so then we've
all done this I mean we've all been
defined by a vision and people in our
life told us it was crazy it's
impossible never work there were days
you didn't feel like it you know all
that stuff but instead you were defined
by that vision and every day you
reviewed that vision and you got excited
about it emotionally and you wrote down
the choices you were going to make and
you wrote down the behaviors you're
going to demonstrate the things you were
going to do and your goals that you
wanted to experience and how they felt
and you kept your mind on that Vision
exactly and then you sat down and you
wrote down okay what are the choices I'm
not going to make today what are the
things I'm not going to do what
experiences am I going to stay away from
and what emotions bring me down to a
lower level let me just get clear on who
I no longer want to be right and if you
reviewed that every day that distinction
between the old self and the new self
there's a lot of pruning going on
neurologically in the brain a lot of
sprouting going on at the same time and
sooner or later you reach a point
where you know that that thing's going
to occur the moment you know it's going
to occur you relax and now you're no
longer trying to control our Force
that's a big moment though that's that
we've all had it when you know when you
know because it takes so much energy to
work for that and you know we're still
in processes many things we want to
create when does that moment how does
that is that a mystical moment or does
it a what happens in the place where you
know that's going to happen I think that
your mind and body all of a sudden align
energetically with that Vision
electromagnetically there's a lock-in
and when you lock into it now you don't
even you you you don't even have to
worry you just know that it's going to
happen you have such a level of
self-love and self-respect for yourself
and for everybody that you actually step
back and allow it to unfold and come to
you so then think of a time in your life
where you said you were going to do
something and you didn't accomplish it
well what happened then you had a vision
you got excited and then and you ran out
of time the next day you didn't feel
like it and you got tired and you got
angry at someone two days ago and you
started putting your attention on your
problems and you know there was you know
you had a lot of social engagements and
you what we do is we settle for our past
present reality instead of that vision
of the future and there's only three
things that do that to us the conditions
in our environment the feelings and
emotions in our body and time so we have
to overcome the conditions of the world
we're living in if we're going to want
the creating the vision of the future
every great person in history understood
that they had to be defined by a vision
of the future and to change is to be
greater than your environment to be
greater than the conditions in your
external world to be greater than the
circumstances in your life
learning to create our minds the way we
want is the basis of creating the world
the way we want
there is a wonderful story in the yogic
law
on a certain day a man took a walk he
went for a long walk
accidentally unawares he walked into
Paradise fortunate isn't he
he just took a walk and he landed up in
Paradise
after this long walk he felt a little
tired
so he thought oh I'm tired I wish I
could rest somewhere
he looked around there there was a nice
tree
underneath which there was very cushiony
grass
so it was inviting he went and put his
head down there and slept
after a few hours he woke up
well rested and he thought oh I'm well
rested but I'm feeling hungry I wish I
had something to eat
and he thought about all the nice things
that he ever wanted to eat in his life
and instantly all those things appeared
in front of him you need to understand
they have the services like that
[Music]
people don't ask questions food came and
he ate
stomach became full then he thought
oh my stomach is full I wish I had
something to drink
[Music]
all the nice things that he ever wanted
to drink
he thought about it and all of them just
appeared
drinking people also don't ask questions
so he drank
now with a little bit of alcohol in him
you know Charles Darwin told you all of
you are monkeys your tail fell away not
me Charles Darwin told you that you were
all monkeys and your tail fell away and
then you became human yes definitely the
tail fell away but the monkey
in yoga we always refer to an
unestablished mind
as murkata which means a monkey
why we are referring to the Mind as a
monkey is
what are the qualities of a monkey
one thing about a monkey is it's
unnecessary moment
[Music]
and another thing about the monkey is if
I say you're monkeying somebody what
does it mean imitation
monkey and imitation have become
synonymous
so these two essential qualities of a
monkey are very much the qualities of an
unestablished mind unnecessary moment
you don't have to learn it from the
monkey you can teach it to the monkey
and imitation is full-time job of the
Mind
so when these two qualities are on a
mind is referred to as a monkey
so this monkey became active within him
he just looked around thought what the
hell is happening here
I asked for food food came
I asked for drink drink came
there must be ghosts around here
and ghost game
oh the ghosts have come they are going
to surround me and torture me he thought
immediately the ghost surrounded him and
started torturing him
then he started screaming in pain and
said oh they're going to kill me and he
died
just now he said he's a fortunate being
the problem is he was sitting under a
kalpa rickshaw or a wishing tree
he asked for food food came he asked for
drink drink came he asked for ghost
ghost came he asked for torture torture
came he asked for death death happened
now don't go looking for these kalpa
rukshas in the forest you can barely
find a tree
these days
a well-established mind
a mind which is in a state of samyukti
is referred to as a cultivation
if you organize your mind to a certain
level of organization it in turn
organizes the whole system
your body your emotion your energies
everything gets organized in the
direction
once all these four dimensions of you
your physical body your mind your
emotion and the fundamental life
energies are organized in One Direction
once you are like this
anything that you wish happens without
even lifting a little finger actually
it would help to assist it with activity
but
even without doing any activity you can
still manifest what you want if you
organize these four dimensions
in One Direction and keep it unwavering
in that direction for a certain period
of time
right now the problem with your mind is
every moment it is changing its
direction
it is like you want to travel somewhere
and every two steps if you keep changing
your direction the question of you
reaching the destination is very remote
unless it happens by chance
so organizing our minds and in turn
organizing the whole system
and these four basic dimensions of who
you are right now in One Direction if
you do this you are a kalpa Brookshire
yourself
anything that you wish will happen
but right now if you look at your lives
everything that you have wished for till
now if it happens you're finished
everything and everybody that you have
desired for if all of that lands up in
your house today could you live with
that
once we're empowered like this it's very
important that our physical action
emotional action mental action and
energy actions are controlled and
properly directed
if it is not so we become destructive
self-destructive right now that is our
problem the technology which is supposed
to make our life beautiful and easy has
become the source of all the problem
that we are destroying the very basis of
our life which is the planet
so what should have been a boon we are
making a curse out of it
what has brought incredible levels of
comfort and convenience to us in the
last
100 years or so has also become a threat
to our life
simply because we are not
conscious action we are in a compulsive
state of action
so organizing our minds fundamentally
means moving from a compulsive state of
activity to a conscious state of
activity
you might have heard of people
for whom they ask for something and
beyond all expectations it came true to
the true for them
generally this happens to people who are
in faith
now let's say you want to build a house
if you start thinking oh I want to build
a house to build a house I need 50 lakhs
but I have only 50 rupees in my pocket
not possible not possible not possible
the moment you say not possible you are
also saying I don't want it
so on one level you're creating a desire
that you want something on another level
you're saying I don't want it so in this
conflict it may not happen
someone who has some faith in a God or
in a temple or whatever
who is her simple-minded Faith Works
only for those people who are
simple-minded thinking people people who
are too much thinking for them it never
works a childlike person
who has a simple faith in his God or his
Temple or whatever
he goes to the temple and says Shiva I
want a house I don't know how you must
make it for me
now in his mind there are no negative
thoughts will it happen will it not
happen is it possible is it not possible
these things are completely removed by
the simple Act of Faith
now he believes Shiva will do it for him
and it will happen
[Music]
so is Shiva going to come and build your
house no I want you to understand God
will not lift his little finger for you
what you refer to as God is a source of
creation
as a Creator he has done a phenomenal
job there's no question about it could
you think of a better creation than this
is it in anybody's imagination to think
anything better than what is there right
now
so as a Creator he has done his job
wonderfully well
but if you want life to happen the way
you want it because right now the very
Crux of your happiness and your
well-being is this
if at all if you're unhappy
the only and only reason why you're
unhappy is life is not happening the way
you think it should happen
that's all it is
so if life is not happening the way you
think it is it should happen you're
unhappy if life happens the way you
think it should happen you are happy
it's as simple as that
so if life has to happen the way you
think it should happen first of all
how you think
with how much Focus you think how much
stability is there in your thought and
how much reverence is there in the
thought process will determine whether
your thought will become a reality or is
it just an empty thought
or
how you do not create any impediments
for your thought by creating negative
thought process
this possible is something possible or
not possible is destroying Humanity
what is possible and not possible is not
your business it's Nature's business
your business is just to strive for what
you want you will never find working a
pleasure if you hate your job or you
can't stand your boss
what a terrible affirmation that is it
will be impossible for you to ever
attract a great job with that belief
system if you want to enjoy your time at
work then you must change your thinking
I'm a great believer in blessing with
love every person place and thing at the
workplace begin with your current job
affirm that this job is merely a
stepping stone to far greater positions
you are in your current job because of
the things you believed in the past you
drew it to you by your thinking perhaps
you learned your attitude towards work
from your parents no matter you can
change your thinking now
so bless with love your boss your
co-workers the location the building the
stairs or elevators the rooms the
furniture and each and every customer
this creates a loving mental atmosphere
within you and the whole office will
respond to it
I have never understood the reasoning
behind putting down or berating others
at work if you are an owner a manager or
a supervisor how can you possibly expect
to get the best work from others if they
are frightened or resentful we all want
to be appreciated acknowledged and
encouraged
if you support your employees and give
them respect then they will give you the
best work they can
now please don't believe that it is hard
to get a job that may be true for many
but it does not have to be true for you
you only need one job and your
Consciousness will open the pathway for
you
don't have faith in fear when you hear
of negative Trends in business or in the
economy immediately affirm that may be
true for some but it is not true for me
I always Prosper no matter where I am or
what is going on
people often ask me for the affirmations
to make the relationships at work be
smoother in fact for many people this is
a really big issue in their lives I am
deeply aware that whatever I give out
comes back to me multiplied and this is
true everywhere including at work
in the workplace it is important to know
that every employee and employer has
been attracted by the action of love for
it's his and her divine right place here
and now at this point in time and space
Divine Harmony permeates us all and we
can all flow together in the workplace
in a most productive and joyous way
there aren't any problems that don't
have Solutions there aren't any
questions without answers
choose to go beyond the problem to seek
the Divine Right action solution to any
Discord that may seem to appear
be willing to learn from any Discord or
confusion as it comes up
it's important to release all blame and
turn within to seek the truth
and be willing to release whatever
pattern may be in your Consciousness
that has contributed to the situation
know that you are successful in all that
you do you're inspired and productive
you serve others willingly and gladly
Divine Harmony Reigns Supreme within and
around you and within and around each
and every person in your workplace
when you know and declare that it's
possible to successfully operate in the
workplace according to Divine principles
then Divine love brings to you those who
can be helped by that which you so
lovingly do
now if you like your job but feel you're
not getting paid enough then bless your
current salary with love
expressing gratitude for what you do
have enables it to grow
and absolutely no more bitching about
the job or co-workers your Consciousness
puts you where you are now your changing
Consciousness can lift you to a better
position you can do it
during your work day there are a number
of things you can do to release tension
here are a few ideas
one before you go to work every day do
this simple exercise just sit
comfortably and concentrate on your
breath
whenever you notice thoughts coming in
gently bring your awareness back to your
breath
give yourself at least 10 or 15 minutes
to dwell in the silence each day there
is nothing difficult or tricky to this
and it's worth taking the time
two write or type this affirmation and
put it where you can see it at work my
job is a peaceful Haven I bless my job
with love I put love in every corner and
my job lovingly responds with warmth and
comfort I am at peace
when you start to think about your boss
say this affirmation to yourself
I only give out that which I wish to
receive my love and acceptance of others
is mirrored to me in every way
refuse to be limited in any way by human
mind thinking
your life can be filled with love and
joy because your work is a Divine idea
remember to say to yourself every day
before going to work no matter where I
am there is only infinite good Infinite
Wisdom infinite Harmony and love
I want to talk a little bit about goals
on the line of
write a book I'm just going to kind of
give you that as an example for 24 years
of my adult life by choice I weighed
well over 200 pounds I say by choice
because you see I have never
accidentally eaten anything
foreign
deliberate
and when I choose to eat too much today
I have chosen to weigh too much tomorrow
you can choose to set goals and realize
your potential or you can choose not to
set them now if you choose not to set
them you got to understand but the
consequences are not going to be good
down the road for 24 years I was going
to lose that weight as a matter of fact
in 24 years I lost several thousand
pounds of weight how many of you already
know exactly what I'm talking about but
it wasn't until I wrote it down put a
date on it listed the obstacles I had to
overcome identify the people the groups
the organizations I needed to work with
spelled out a plan of action set that
time limit in there and identified all
of the benefits to me it was only when I
did that that the goal became a real
reality and I lost the weight for 10 or
15 years I was gonna write a book you
know anybody who's going to do just a
whole lot of things folks I was going to
write a book but it wasn't until I got
busy writing the book and writing the
plans first before the book ever
materialized now if it sound like I'm
trying to sell you on Heaven goals how
many of you are getting close already
how many of you have been coming
convinced right quick like that you need
to have those goals there's no question
about it the immortal JC Penney many
many years ago said give me a stock
clerk with a goal and I'll give you a
man who will make history but give me a
man without a goal and I'll give you a
stock clerk
now the interesting thing is gold
let's do this then let me give you a
classic example of the way they work in
1950 a war-torn devastated to Japan a
nationhood had lost an incredibly high
percentage of its young men their cities
were in Ruins they'd been bombed out but
in 1950 they got together they meaning
industry and government got together and
set a goal the goal was we're going to
be the number one nation in the world
during the 1950s in the production of
textiles in 1959 ladies and gentlemen
they accomplished that objective in
19060 they said
they sold we're going to be the number
one
number we'll stand there's no iron ore
in Japan of any significance there's no
coal of any significance there we're
going to be the number one nation in the
world in the production of Steel it
seemed like an absurd goal and yet they
reached their objectives they had taken
all of the steps in 1970 the Japanese
said another goal they said during the
70s we'll be the number one nation in
the world in the production of
automobiles they missed it folks one
year it took them until 1980. in 1980
they said enough old and this time
they're
yes indeed ladies and gentlemen you
absolutely must have those goals you got
to write them down you got to put a date
on it you got to identify those
obstacles you've got identify the people
the groups you need to work with you've
got to find out what it is you need to
know you got to develop a plan of action
and you got to write it down what's in
it for me now that's a formula that I
have just given you pure and simple and
I hear this from
boards but I'm not manifesting one
reason you're not manifesting is because
you don't believe in what you're trying
to manifest
when you believe it you'll receive it
but if you don't believe it then you're
just trying pushing control and try to
make something happen that isn't fully
ingrained in your presence in your being
in your energy
and so you have to do your part to get
into the belief system of knowing that
this is indeed
something you are worthy of so how do
you get into that grounded belief system
create a vision statement a statement
that claims that your desire is on the
way that you are worthy of what it is
that you desire ground yourself in that
statement focus on it and instead of
focusing on the outcome focus on the
feeling of what it is to believe and
know that you are worthy of your desire
if you're wanting to attract a romantic
partner into your life a vision
statement could sound like I believe I'm
worthy of the love that I desire where I
believe that I am ready to receive that
romantic relationship in the perfect
time and Order say that vision statement
daily for at least 40 days get yourself
grounded in the belief you have to
believe it to receive it the next reason
you're not manifesting
because you're trying too hard
sorry to say it but it's true the more
you push the more you control the more
you try the more you affirm the more you
vision board the more the more the more
the less you receive if you're pushing
and you're controlling and you're trying
to make something happen if you are
completely out of alignment with the
universe you're not aligned with that
freedom that presence of Love The Art of
allowing rather than doing forcing
making happen yeah we have to show up
for our life but we can't force our
dreams to become a reality so the key
here is to let go so here's your message
the secret to manifesting is to forget
what you think you need let it go how do
you let it go with this intention
thank you Universe for guiding me to
what is of the highest good for all when
you make it about the highest good and
not about what you think you need then
the universe can truly show up for you
you can relax and allow even more than
you could imagine to enter into your
life
and here's another reason that you're
not manifesting this is going to be
tough for you to hear
because you're not vibrating at the
right frequency
what do you mean well what I mean is
that you're leaning into the negative
you're judging a lot you are focusing on
scary things that make you so anxious
and you just keep focusing on them and
dwelling on them you're obsessed with
worrying you love to overthink things
look I understand that behavior more
than anyone could imagine I'm a
recovering Warrior I'm a recovering
anxious person I've been there I
understand that but when we are not in
that vibration that's relaxed released
at ease present
we're actually blocking our
manifestations because that low Vibe
energy is blocking our high Vibe
attracting power so what do you do focus
on the good stuff lean into the positive
look for Solutions rather than problems
stop yourself when you notice that
you're being judgmental or gossipy hang
out with people that make you feel good
do things that make you feel good lean
towards joy and you will be led
when you dwell in that energy of Joy the
universe will deliver so if you're not
attracted attracting you desire just
relax it's all good focus on these
methods notice when you're out of
alignment and come back to this video
practice one of these methods use these
tools ground yourself back into
alignment believe it to receive it feel
good and it will come to you naturally
we have the power within us to attract
what we desire when we allow our
internal condition to reflect what we
want to attract on the outside so make
that your highest priority I used to
struggle a lot with manifesting just the
idea of it I would watch videos on it
and I didn't understand what they were
saying I didn't I just didn't understand
it what was manifest in a lot of
attractions like what are they saying I
don't understand the words that are
coming out of your mouth and I would
rewind and watch again it's like I don't
get it I don't understand I don't I
don't understand and it seemed weird
silly not good enough for me to just sit
on the couch and think about money
coming into your wallet or whatever it
was that you're trying to manifest you
got to go do something that in law of
attraction you know action is at the end
of Attraction like you got to go off and
do the work if that's been you if you've
been kind of struggling with manifesting
or Law of Attraction you don't know how
it makes sense you rewind videos and it
feels too woo-woo for you let me uh let
me let me explain it from a different
perspective and and maybe it'll help at
least this is what's helped me the first
thing that I realized is
very scientific is from the reticular
activating systems as part of your brain
that decides what to pay attention to
and what to not pay attention to there
there are so many things that are
happening right now all around you that
you are not paying attention to most
things your brain filters out your the
job of the reticular activating system
you can go look it up Ras is to filter
out most things and only filter in the
things that you should care about so for
example
um you know what color are your socks
today what color is your underwear today
you know looking down this street and
you know I didn't know that there was a
pine tree here what are you paying
attention to as you look out the window
you're looking at the tree you're
looking at the the sign here you're
looking at the driveway you look at the
color of the sky you're looking at the
house you look at the what material that
might be you're not looking at anything
again just too blurry you're still
looking at my face you're looking at my
car you're looking at the color of the
headrest you're looking at my outfit
like what are you paying attention to
most things you're ignoring
because there's no possible way to pay
attention to everything potentially the
dog just Anna hello good girl
right we're ignoring most things because
it wouldn't serve you it's just
impossible to be information overload if
you feel like you're overloaded already
just imagine if you took in absolutely
everything so your eyes are bringing it
in and your brain is filtering out most
of it so what does your brain actually
pay attention to well the reticular
activating system
will choose to say okay you've set an
intention right I want to pay attention
to X and now all of a sudden you're
going to see that more often I I'm I
just bought a house so in that process
we started paying attention a lot more
to houses so one of the things I noticed
was the for sale sign here where I may
have not noticed that as much in the
past but because thinking house boom now
I'm paying attention to the for sale
sign you ever notice when you buy a car
you start seeing that car everywhere
right or even thinking about buying a
car you're thinking about buying an X
you start seeing it on the street more
often
why that's your reticular activating
system basically saying I want to pay
attention to those things so that car
was still around right I mean I I got
this car we've got a Porsche and now I
see Porsches more often those Porsches
still existed they were they were
already there I just didn't notice them
before and now I notice them because I
have one right
um so whatever it is that you want
whatever it is that you're setting
attention towards it's not just sit on
your couch and meditate and imagine
money coming into your wallet or a new
car or new house or business growth or
you speaking on stage or whatever your
goals are right it's not just
sitting on it and visualizing it but
it's noticing it and the elements of it
in your environment that when you start
thinking about it right we are we we
consistently think about when you start
thinking about it you'll start seeing
opportunities around you that were
already there
you just filtered it out because you
didn't see how it connected now your
brain's starting to make those
connections does that make sense
reticular activating system you're
ignoring most things
but when you set intention on the thing
that matters to you you'll start seeing
it in your environment and opportunities
for that to happen a lot more often so
that's step number one reticular
activating system it's the science
number two is to trust your intuition
more one of the things that really
helped me back early on in my career was
I
judge myself too harshly for the ideas
that I came up with and as soon as I
came up with an idea I was like oh you
can't do that or I had to have the
perfect Plan before I would ever take
any kind of action on it and you know
just later realize that you can never
plan all the way out there's no way you
know if you wait till you have the
perfect plan by the time you start
actually executing the plan is is dead
it's over
um and so you have to trust in your
ideas and so the thing that really
helped me is
I believe that great ideas flow through
me believe the great ideas flow through
you this is how you shortcut them your
brain that's designed to keep you safe
that's how you show cut the brain out of
the equation
you came up with an idea as long as it's
in you're in a positive state of mind
you're trying to serve right it's not I
want to I want to go you're you're in a
jealous Rage or you're angry don't trust
your ideas then
but when when you're positive and
optimistic and bold and courageous and
an idea comes to you trust that that's
the right idea for you just trust it
it's already and then go do something
about it where normally what we do is we
overthink and we over plan we over
prepare and then we lose the momentum
and then the next day and the next week
or the next month it's gone it's over
it's like oh I can't do that no that was
actually a great idea for you and it's
happened enough to me
uh where those things have worked out
where I come up with an idea
and it doesn't make any sense
logically
but I just decide to listen to it and do
something on it and it leads to
something amazing
the amount of times that has happened
is
pretty overwhelming
and so when you have enough repetition
for me I had to see it you know I had to
see it enough times come up because I
wouldn't just believe it on faith I had
to see it happen enough times and you
could test it yourself what ideas in
your head what big idea that you want to
do even a small idea what's what's
flowing through your head when you're in
a positive State you know put on a happy
song move around a little bit and then
notice your thoughts and where it's
going and what you want to create or who
you want to reach out to what you want
to do like what what thought comes to
mind after you're moving around and
having some positive energy that's
probably the right thing for you and
just test it out by doing something
about it and maybe that's a business
idea maybe that's an email you need to
send maybe that's a friend you need to
reach out to maybe that's an act of
kindness that you need to do whatever
the thing is that pops into your mind
trust those ideas and and you could be a
scientist like I'm I like data and I
like science and I like just I like
proving things maybe I'm a skeptic I
don't know but in running those
experiments I proved to myself that yeah
great ideas do flow through me
and so the next time I have a great idea
I'm gonna go and take action on it so
number one reticular activating system
it's already in your environment you're
just ignoring it but if you put
attention towards you start seeing it
like you notice a new car uh when you
buy your new car you see that car
everywhere and then number two is trust
a good ideas flow through you
number three is the one that I'm working
on that I'm I'm having the hardest time
with and I I believe it and I'm trying
to I'm in the process of getting better
at it is
when you're thinking about creating
something to talk to yourself in the
present moment
and this is something that a lot of the
manifestation a lot of Attraction people
talk about but also
people like Grant Cardone talk about it
uh that it's it's not just
the people who would associate with it
but other people have had a lot of
success where you're talking about
whatever thing is that you want that
it's that it's already happened that
it's not going to happen in the future
but that it's already happened you know
if your goal is to speak on stage then
you're visualizing and you're telling
yourself I I am I am on stage I am
speaking to
I am speaking to a million people or
that's that's a giant Stadium
some people you know I am I am the
author of a best-selling book uh I am
like whatever your goal is and what I
think the point of that is is yes one to
see yourself accomplishing big things uh
two to not have a be so far away that it
lets you off the hook for taking action
but I think most importantly is for you
to feel what it feels like to be that
and the more you feel like it feels like
to be that the more it actually becomes
true if your goal is to speak on stage
in front of 5 000 people
and you actually
feel like you're doing it you can
visualize yourself being on stage and
doing it
the goal I think I'm still working
through this so one and two I've got
down three is my progress and my journey
so sharing with you
if you feel like you're doing it
if you are on stage and there's 5 000
people clapping for you and cheering you
you just gave the best speech you know
of your life so far
and you feel what it feels like to walk
off that stage and
what a gift that you gave people
that the more comfortable you get with
that feeling
the more it's going to be you and the
more that's going to show up does that
make sense so whatever it is that you
are trying to accomplish
whoever it is that you're trying to be
whatever your big goals are
that you imagine yourself already having
done it
and this is probably not something I
would tell other people you know like oh
yeah yeah I'm a I'm a you know I'm a
speaker in front of 70 000 people
because because
I haven't spoken at a stadium that big
but
to yourself at least
to say it to see it to feel it to do it
if you're trying to heal yourself like
okay I am I am healthy
David but look I've got a got a belly or
I've got a you know whatever I'm I'm I
am healthy I am healthy and and
visualizing yourself being healthy
because you want the feeling of what it
feels like to be healthy and the more
you feel like you are healthy and you
capture that feeling the more frequently
you're in there the more likely it's
going to show up
so that's probably not the most
articulate way to share it and I'm still
working my way through it as well so as
I keep getting better and keep learning
I'll keep sharing with you but
I used to think like
manifestation law of attraction was way
out there stuff that that I judged and
that I didn't understand and that didn't
make any sense like just go off and take
action guys and
with time and experience and exposure
and practice
um using the reticular activating system
to notice things around me by trusting
that great ideas flow through me and
following through and building momentum
and by talking to myself in the present
moment as if I am that person that I
want to become so I can capture that
feeling and know what it feels like to
be that person
I've shifted and seen some pretty
amazing results in my life in business
and I hope it can work for you too
because you made it this far in a video
I want to celebrate you most people
start and don't finish most people never
actually follow through most people say
they want something but they don't ever
do the work to actually get it but
you're different you are special believe
Nation you made it here all the way to
the end and I love you so it's a special
celebration if you put a hashtag believe
down in the comments Below on this video
I will showcase you and celebrate you
somewhere on the screen in a future
video because you are awesome to learn
how to make your visualizations come
true with Joe dispenza check the video
right there next to me I think you'll
love it continue to believe and I'll see
you there if they feel their abundance
or their worthiness before they have
their wealth it will start generating
abundance if they start being in love
with themselves and being in love with
life they'll create an equal that's the
law